British Air power in Russia's backyard
typhoon Jets Patrol estonia's skies on a
mission to deter aggression
but back on the ground anger is growing
with the head of the royal air force
over a botched recruitment drive that's
damaged morale and could have impacted
capability
Sky News has seen emails exposing the
pressure put on RAF recruitment officers
to attract more women and ethnic
minorities
one email dated the 19th of January 2021
from a squadron leader talked about
selection boards for new recruits saying
they'd been predominantly white male
heavy I don't really need to see loads
of useless white male Pilots
selection boards are how the RAF chooses
candidates to start training courses and
are a vital process to maintain the
forces fighting strength
but another email dated the 20th of
January 2021 revealed we've canceled two
boards next week due to them having no
female black Asian and minority ethnic
or priority branch on them
I've also been told by a source and Via
a freedom of information request that at
least one white man officially
complained he'd been unfairly
disadvantaged by this kind of
recruitment policy as a white male he'd
been held back from joining a cyber
training program and missed out on a 5
000 pound bonus the RAF has since found
30 other white men in a similar position
my source says they're all being paid
five thousand pounds and there could be
many other white men also impacted
air Chief Marshals sir Mike wigston
denied any discrimination when he gave
evidence to MPS in February but the head
of the defense committee isn't convinced
and is waiting for the findings of an
inquiry into the crisis
on the face of it it does look like the
committee was misled when the report
comes out I will seek uh guidance from
my committee and invite
Amos wigston back into the committee to
answer questions and we'll put this very
very issue to him
the inquiry was launched after the
resignation of group Captain Elizabeth
Nichol who took charge of recruitment in
March 2021
Sky News exclusively revealed she then
quit last year in protest at what she
deemed to be an unlawful order to
discriminate against white men
Skies K Burley then challenged the RAF
boss
and in any way do you feel that safety
was compromised by the fact that ethnic
minorities and women if I may finish the
question were favored over others
okay there was there was absolutely no
drop in operational standards no drop in
any standards there was no discriminate
discrimination against any any group
continue to do everything possible to
increase recruiting from
underrepresented groups within the
provisions of the law
at a ceremony this week the head of the
Air Force will hand over this goal to
his successor along with lots of
difficult questions